taoufik jebali alors on le disait un la
police de washington a confirmé qu'un
policier avait tiré sur cette femme une
républicaine pro trump est ce que ça
peut avoir des conséquences politiques
selon vous cette révélation de la police
de washington
je ne pense pas parce que pour une
partie des américains ils vont
considérer que c'était sa faute
pour d'autres j'ai trouvé que c'était
intéressant de voir que cette dame avait
servi dans l'armée américaine pendant 14
ans si j'ai bien compris
donc l'armée américaine a une place tout
à fait spécifique est tout à fait
spéciale dans le coeur des américains
donc de là à voir une tout d'abord une
dame
deuxièmement une disons soldats ou une
en tout cas quelqu'un qui avait servi
l'armée américaine c'est sur le plan
symbolique quelque chose de très
intéressant
je pense que malheureusement pour elle
elle va être vite oublié parce que pour
les hommes politiques américains
ce qui les intéresse c'est de garder la
main sur le système politique c'est de
maintenir ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
américaine en marche
et puis cette dame a les victimes d'une
peut-être d'une situation tout à fait
exceptionnelle mais en tout cas pour
beaucoup d'américains ils vont penser
que c'était elle avait cherché la
prochaine étape
taoufik c'est évidemment la prestation
de serment de joe biden le 20 janvier
prochain
une prestation de serment quelque peu
entachée oui certainement
certainement et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si tu ramasses parce vas y vas
participer à cette cérémonie
moi je à priori je ne pense pas mais ça
va être entachée ça va être la première
fois où ça se passe dans des conditions
extrêmement confuse il ne va pas y avoir
du monde autour d'eux
autour de cette cérémonie parce que tout
d'abord il y avait le lac au vide mais
aussi il ya cette situation tout à fait
exceptionnelle et y avoir d'autres
manifestations à prévoir justement pour
le 20 janvier oui je pense oui oui si
c'est pas à washington
évidemment si on prend la décision de ne
pas autoriser une manifestation à
washington
il se peut qu'il y ait d'autres
manifestations ailleurs mais à mon avis
les partisans de 30 ne vont pas baisser
la garde et ils vont continuer pour un
certain temps pour quelques semaines
peut-être quelques mois à manifester
leur désaccord leurs frustrations et est
certainement leur âge par rapport à ses
résultats par rapport à ce qu'il pense
cette fraude massive selon eux deux les
élections présidentielles donc il va y
avoir certainement des suites
donald trump 1 qui continue toujours de
parler de fraude électorale sans pour
autant en apporter les preuves
quelle posture selon vous il va pouvoir
tenir désormais jusqu'au 20 janvier
à mon avis je pense qu'il va peut-être
se calmer un petit peu et il va
certainement essayer d'apaiser parce que
là ça sa sortie elle est assurée il n'a
plus de recours et n'a plus de chance de
rester à la maison blanche
donc quelque part et là tout intérêt
mais comme il est imprévisible
je ne peux pas vous dire quel sera son
comportement mais je pense qu'il va
certainement faire un petit peu le mar
pour un certain temps en attendant le
vin le 20 janvier comme ça il va
s'éclipser dans des conditions peut-être
pas tout à fait honorable pour lui parce
que tout d'abord il avait perdu c'est
quelqu'un qui déteste perdre et surtout
perdre contre d'ailleurs il avait dit à
perdre contre contre baye dans ses
quelque chose d'impensable pour lui donc
certainement et c'est quelqu'un qui
psychologiquement sera démoli le 20
janvier pour un certain temps il est en
ce moment à un recul à la maison blanche
donald trump
il y a une autre information qui a été
éclipsé cette nuit c'est le congrès le
sénat qui a qui bascule en tout cas à
majorité démocrate et ça ça va changer
la donne sur la politique américaine
oui oui ça cet homme je les tice c'est
un événement très important que ce soit
sur le plan politique que sur le plan
symbolique sur le plan symbolique il
faut savoir que les démocrates n'ont pas
gagné la géorgie depuis les années 60
mais sachez juste un petit rappel les
démocrates s'étaient des
ultraconservateurs est à l'origine le
parti démocrate était un parti
réactionnaire esclavagiste et le parti
républicain c'est le parti d'abraham
lincoln c'était un parti progressiste
donc à partir des années 60 quand il y
avait le basculement du parti démocrate
plus vers la gauche et le basculement
des républicains vers la droite vers le
conservatisme depuis la géorgie le
bastion avec peut-être le mississippi et
l'alabama
le bastion du conservatisme de l'ultra
conservatisme américain pour la première
fois on voit un changement et ce
changement et les d'autant plus
intéressant que finalement un décès ces
deux sénateurs qui viennent de gagner
est un afro-américain donc sur le plan
symbolique il y avait deux choses
importantes
tout d'abord l'élection d'alain froid
américains pour la première fois de
l'histoire de la géorgie
et deuxièmement la géorgie qui passe
dans le giron du parti démocrate c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel dire
maintenant que le sénat bascule dans le
camp des démocrates
il va y avoir 50 50 mais comme le
président du sénat c'est le vice
président des états unis il quand il ya
blocage c'est pour vice président et ses
camarades kamala harris qui qui va
trancher dans ce cas là les démocrates
vont jouer plutôt gagnant dans ceux de
roms et quatre années à venir
mais cela dit juste un point ce n'est
pas parce qu'on est démocrate convainc
voter systématiquement avec les
démocrates
il n'y a pas une unité de partis aux
états unis il n'y a pas de consignes de
parti pratiquement chacun vote comme il
veut chacun vote en fonction de ses
administrés de l'opinion publique des
sondages et on peut imaginer aussi que
même avec 50 50
et même avec le vote de kamala harris
ce n'est pas gagné pour bariton parce
que il ya énormément de démocrates
conservateurs et dans ce cas là on les
appelle d'ailleurs les blue dogs in vote
sans complexe avec les républicains
alors est-ce que concernant l'avenir de
donald trump à ce qu'on peut imaginer
qu'il puisse être jugé après les propos
qu'il a tenus lors de son discours il a
appelé à marcher sur le capitole on va
peut-être pouvoir l'entendre d'ailleurs
d'ici quelques secondes
en tout cas taoufik jebali est ce que
c'est une option qui est sur la table
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas tout d'abord
parce que appelé à manifester est un
droit fondamental est un droit garanti
par la constitution est garantie par le
premier amendement de la constitution
donc sur ce plan là on ne peut pas
reprocher à attrape d'avoir appelé à
manifester devant le carré d'honneur
s'est il n'avait pas appelé directement
à la violence il n'avait pas appelé
directement à une intrusion au 102 de la
forteresse du congrès il avait tout
simplement appelé mais avec des messages
encore une fois qu d'aidé message
indirect mais en tout cas il avait
appelé ses partisans de rester en garde
deux de se mettre près à d'autres
éventualités
mais cela dit je ne pense pas que le
fait d'appeler à une manifestation même
dans des conditions extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement difficile appelé à
manifester n'est pas un délit aux états
unis injuste
bon on va l'entendre donald trump
c'était lors de son discours dans le
milieu de l'après midi devant la maison
blanche donald trump s'est adressé à ses
partisans qui s'étaient massés justement
devant devant la maison blanche écoutez
[Musique]
nous tous ici présents ne voulons pas
voir notre victoire électorale volés par
des démocrates plein d'audace de la
gauche radicale car c'est ce qu'ils font
est volé par les pseudo médias car c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait et ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire nous n'abandonnerons
jamais nous ne concédons jamais comment
est-ce que vous qualifieriez finalement
la fin de deux mandats de donald trump
s'est tout d'abord il faut la comparer
avec le début je crois qu'il est arrivé
à un moment où on attendait pas mais il
avait fait un parcours plutôt on
considère que son parcours était
honorable jusqu'à l'arrivée de la
pandémie de du mois de février mars et
donc la fin elle est décevante
certainement pour lui elle est dans la
confusion parce que sur le plan
politique c'est une confusion tout à
fait une
c'est une situation tout à fait inédite
je pense qu'il rate sa sortie
excusez-moi l'expression mais
certainement il aurait pu gagner les
élections s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
pandémie et il avait mal géré et
évidemment sur le plan sanitaire mal
géré la pandémie
et dans ce cas là il paye évidemment ça
ça ces décisions politiques pas tout à
fait pertinente et aujourd'hui la sortie
elle est vraiment douloureuse pour lui
douleureuse aussi pour l'amérique qui
voit sa démocratie trébucher un petit
peu même si ils vont remonter la pente
mais l'américain toujours façonné sa
propagande autour de la solidité de son
système démocratique
on voit aujourd'hui et même pendant ces
quatre dernières années que cette
démocratie qui faisait évidemment
honneur à tous les américains
apparemment cette démocratie elle
s'avère extrêmement fragile faire face à
des événements de l'ampleur qu'on vient
de voir
merci beaucoup taoufik jebali d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur la matinale
des ratés france je le rappelle vous
êtes maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine